the farle will be more organized than
law enforcement the reason
is the the the antifa cels are in loose
communication with each other but they
have no external threat Factor if the
federal government gets into it with
Texas and it's like it's very light I
don't know if this this will actually
escalate the border patrol is already
sided with Texas National Guard we'll
see where that goes but let's say the
conflict between the feds and this and
and Texas escalates into several other
states it's like a Mexican standoff the
feds are way too preoccupied are not
going to be able to muster up any kind
of forces to stop farle farle extremists
from seizing territory in major cities
and local police cut off from the feds
are going to just ditch they're going to
back I'm out we remember what happened
when the far leftists went to the police
station in Minnesota in Minneapolis what
happened all the cops ran full speed out
of the building they were not organized
in the way people think they are the
far-left is or at least willing to do
crazy things so that's what I kind of
see happening I don't know